Nick Cannon
one of the most
fertile I guess you wouldn't call him
fertile you'd call him prolific maybe
you'd call them very active and busy uh
celebrities out there
he's got something like 10 kids with
almost as many babies mama is it baby
mamas or baby's mama is it like an
attorney's General I don't know I'm not
totally familiar with that culture
anyway Nick Cannon is discussing how
complicated it is to go buy Christmas
presents
it's almost the holidays and thanks to
me the world now has 8 billion people
but my job's not done it's time to do
some online Christmas shopping and based
off the baby mama the kid ratio we got a
whole hell of a lot of gifts to buy
let's go
[Music]
and it started off my adorable and
jovial Offspring gave me a list
Daddy's got this it's gonna be a merry
Christmas I didn't get none of this
stuff when I was a kid no my daddy got
me a stick used to call me stick candy
Matthew Mark Luke and John are those
books in the Bible are more kid names no
I can't afford the whole Lakers maybe
one of them I could probably purchase
one Laker all these damn gifts y'all
just don't want to go to college well
PS5
how about I give you a p two and a half
I think I got carpal tunnel hahaha get
it he's got a ton of kids with a bunch
of different women and so he's got to
buy all these Christmas presents for
them hahaha
producer Danny who is much more up on
pop culture than I am informs me it's
not that Nick Cannon has upwards of 10
kids Danny seems to think that he's got
11 going on 12 kids whatever the number
is Nick Cannon in a more serious
interview said quote
being a father of multiple kids it's
always the biggest guilt on me is that I
don't get to spend enough time with all
my children one because I'm constantly
working and two because I'm just spread
thin
a lot of people knock Nick Cannon
because he goes around and impregnates
all of these women and isn't married to
them and doesn't form a stable family
and is very irresponsible the reason I
don't go after Nick Cannon as hard as
some people do is I always think
at least he doesn't kill the kids
it's sad that that is the bar in our
society
but our society murders 850 000 babies a
year so if you don't kill your kids
you are already starting at a higher
place than that Baseline in our culture
and I genuinely give Nick Cannon credit
for that
now of course we want to raise our
standards a little bit and the reason
the Nick Cannon feels guilt is because
he's doing something that is shameful
he is intentionally depriving children
of a stable family okay
you are supposed to have children
within the context of marriage marriage
is the lifelong Union the Perpetual
Union of a man and a woman of a husband
and a wife for the good of the spouses
and the sake of the generation and
education of children lots of people
this doesn't totally work out or they
make mistakes and they later come to
repent it and I get it it's a very
Fallen World people have Blended
families and all these sorts of things
but
repenting and trying to make the best of
a bad situation in a fallen world is
very different from intentionally
creating the sort of chaotic and
disordered circumstances that will
that will continue to spread in that
Fallen World okay
and Nick Cannon seems to be very much in
the latter category it's not just that
Nick Cannon had a wild kind of early
life and now he's settling down with a
family and trying to do right by the
rest of his kids that he had wronged
it's the app is still knocking up all of
these different women and he's telling
jokes about it and it reminds me of a
line from Chesterton
Chesterton pointed out that the problem
of the modern world is not that it's too
evil but that it's too good
except it's it's good in a way not where
the virtues all work together to give
you a flourishing Society it's good in
the sense that people take one virtue
and they just pursue that relentlessly
and they ignore all of the other virtues
that the virtues have been separated and
they're wandering around aimlessly and
recklessly so Nick Cannon as I gave him
credit at the top he's not killing his
kids he recognizes that it's a good
thing to have kids and it is a lot of
Elites in our society don't realize that
people like Bill Gates people especially
Bill Gates because he's obsessed with
trying to reduce the number of kids that
people have people like our our whole
contraceptive mentality and our abortive
mentality and the Looney Tunes at the
world economic Forum in the U.N
trying to push abortion and
contraception and deal with
overpopulation that supposed problem
it's a it's a nonsense of course Elon
Musk points out rightly that the world
actually has an underpopulation problem
but that's a topic for another time so
Nick Cannon gets it he gets that it's
good be fruitful and multiply man is
made in the image and likeness of God it
is a good thing to have kids
but he has divorced that virtuous
insight
from all the other virtues which is it's
good to have families children have a
right to their natural father and mother
join together in marriage children have
a right to be conceived in the conjugal
act within the context of marriage
Nick Cannon has has divorced the the
good Insight from all of the contexts
surrounding so he he really ought to
correct himself we all really ought to
correct ourselves as well and we can
recognize the right especially in this
crazy world I I I'm reminded of a book
by Aleister McIntyre it's called after
virtue where he describes our current
moral situation as people in this
post-nuclear kind of apocalyptic world
the whole civilization all of human
knowledge has been blown up and they
find kind of scraps of a science
textbook you know one equation here one
little commentary on physics here and
from that we've got to piece back
together the whole of human scientific
knowledge that's where that's where we
are right now when it comes to morality
and ethics
okay Nick Cannon it's right be fruitful
and multiply well what what does that
mean man has made the image of likeness
of God great what does that mean what
does that mean for your family I mean
stop going out and trying to find new
baby's mama and
raise your raise your family and settle
down and get married and
within that context have more kids
[Music]
[Music]